It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose GoogleFi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的生意规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 GoogleFi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢忙碌时，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是个不会过期的优惠。立即探索 GoogleFi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. A beautiful sunset, a skinned knee, a sad movie, a pungent onion. What do all of these things have in common? Any of them might, under the right circumstances, make you cry. In recent years, psychologists and other researchers have begun digging into the psychology and neurobiology of crying, testing out the truth behind common myths about tears and learning more about why we cry. So what does psychological purpose or purposes of crying? What do tears of sadness and tears of joy have in common, and how do they differ? Does having a good cry really make you feel better when you're sad or upset? Why do some people cry more easily than others? And if you're in a situation where you don't want to
GoogleFi Wireless 在网络使用高峰期不会受到数据流量降速的影响。美丽的日落、擦伤的膝盖、悲伤的电影、刺鼻的洋葱。这些事物有什么共同点？在适当的情况下，它们中的任何一个都可能让你流泪。近年来，心理学家和其他研究人员开始深入研究哭泣的心理学和神经生物学，验证关于眼泪的常见误区，并进一步了解我们为什么会哭。那么，哭泣的心理目的或目的究竟是什么？悲伤的泪水和喜悦的泪水有什么共同点，又有什么区别？当你感到悲伤或心烦意乱时，痛快地哭一场真的能让你感觉好些吗？为什么有些人比其他人更容易哭？如果你处于一种不想
cry, is it possible to stop yourself from doing so? And is that a good thing? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that exists. the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Lauren Bilesma, a licensed clinical psychologist and an associate professor of psychiatry and psychology at the University of Pittsburgh. She's been studying crying for nearly two decades and has done research on the neurobiology
哭泣的情况下，有可能阻止自己吗？这样做是好事吗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是劳伦·拜尔斯玛博士，她是一位持证临床心理学家，也是匹兹堡大学精神病学和心理学副教授。她研究哭泣近二十年，并对哭泣的神经生物学、
of crying, the social and psychological functions of tears and crying in therapy. She also studies emotion regulation and mood and anxiety disorders, including emotional functioning in depression and cognitive behavioral therapy for mood, anxiety, and schizophrenia spectrum disorders. Dr. Bosma, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me. Let's start with a question that I asked in the intro, which is, why do we cry? What purpose or purposes do tears serve?
眼泪的社会和心理功能以及治疗中的哭泣进行了研究。她还研究情绪调节以及心境和焦虑障碍，包括抑郁症中的情绪功能，以及针对心境、焦虑和精神分裂症谱系障碍的认知行为疗法。拜尔斯玛博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。谢谢您的邀请。让我们从我在开场白中提出的一个问题开始，那就是，我们为什么会哭？眼泪有什么目的或作用？
Yeah, so it's a complicated question. So you mentioned a few types of tears in the overview. So there are the basal tears which lubricate the eye, which humans and all animals have. these or most animals, then there's the reflexive tears that might be in response to something irritating like cutting an onion. But I think the tears that we're most interested in talking about today, which is the focus of my work is the emotional tears, which are in response to an emotional situation. So in terms of the emotional tears, people vary in the types of things that they cry to, but it seems to be specific to a really intense emotional response, which could be
嗯，这是一个复杂的问题。你在概述中提到了几种眼泪。有润滑眼睛的基础泪，人类和所有动物都有。或者说大多数动物都有。然后是反射性泪，这可能是对切洋葱等刺激物的反应。但我认为我们今天最感兴趣讨论的，也是我工作重点的，是情绪性泪水，即对情绪化情境的反应。就情绪性泪水而言，人们因之哭泣的事物类型各不相同，但它似乎特定于一种非常强烈的情绪反应，这可能是
something negative, really distressing or sad or something really positive or awe-inspiring as well, but all involving really intense emotional experience. So you mentioned a couple of common reasons why people cry. Is there anything that almost universally makes people cry? Yeah, that's a good question. It's a little more variable in adults, but among babies and children, they will cry in response to pain or other forms of distress. There are some adults that may report never crying as an adult. are very rarely crying, but I would say at least developmentally in those early stages, that is pretty universal, that pain or distress. Now, crying among infants is different, though, isn't it?
负面的、非常痛苦或悲伤的事情，也可能是非常积极或令人敬畏的事情，但都涉及非常强烈的情绪体验。你提到了人们哭泣的几个常见原因。有什么几乎普遍会让人们哭泣的事情吗？嗯，这是一个好问题。在成年人中，这更具可变性，但在婴儿和儿童中，他们会因疼痛或其他形式的痛苦而哭泣。有些成年人可能报告说成年后从不哭泣，或者很少哭泣，但我会说，至少在发育的早期阶段，因疼痛或痛苦而哭泣是相当普遍的。现在，婴儿的哭泣是不同的，不是吗？
I mean, they don't initially produce tears, correct? That's right. In the very early stages before the lacquimile ducks fully form in the first few weeks, there's no physical tears, but there is the vocalizations and the sounds that the infants make. Does everyone cry? I mean, why do some people cry more easily than other? Yeah, there's a lot of different factors that might contribute to how often someone cries. There are certainly some adults that report never crying at all.
我的意思是，他们最初不会产生眼泪，对吧？没错。在最初的阶段，在出生后的头几周泪腺完全形成之前，没有物理上的眼泪，但婴儿会发出声音和啼哭。每个人都会哭吗？我的意思是，为什么有些人比其他人更容易哭？嗯，有很多不同的因素可能导致一个人哭泣的频率。确实有一些成年人报告说从不哭泣。
That seems to be somewhat rare, and it might be that they don't remember times that they cried or they might be less willing to admit it. So that hasn't been fully verified if that is the case, if there's some people who literally never cry, at least in terms of emotional tears, those people would still cry, you know, if they were to cut an onion or something like that. There are some people who may be have a disease of the lacrimal glands who might not be able to produce tears, but might experience other things that go along with crying. But there are a number of factors. One of them is biological sex, so women cry three to five times more than men.
这似乎比较罕见，可能是因为他们不记得自己哭过的时候，或者他们可能不太愿意承认。所以，如果确实存在完全不哭的人，至少在情绪性泪水方面，这一点尚未得到完全证实。这些人如果切洋葱之类的，还是会哭的。有些人可能患有泪腺疾病，无法产生眼泪，但可能会经历伴随哭泣的其他反应。但有很多因素。其中之一是生理性别，女性哭泣的频率是男性的三到五倍。
And that's something we've seen across all different cultures. And there's a number of reasons for that. Part of it could be women in general tend to be more emotionally expressive than men. So there may be some cultural influence. But because we also see that across the world, there's probably some other biological reasons as well, perhaps neurological differences or hormones, but we don't really know the exact reasons. Those are kind of speculative. Are there cultural differences in crying? Have you looked across various nationalities, for example? Yeah, there was a study, a large survey across the world of crying conducted in 2008. And there were some subtle differences across different. cultures, but overall, there was actually really striking similarity as well.
这是我们在所有不同文化中都观察到的现象。这有很多原因。部分原因可能是女性通常比男性更善于表达情感。所以可能存在一些文化影响。但因为我们在世界各地都观察到这一点，所以可能还有其他生物学原因，也许是神经学差异或荷尔蒙，但我们并不真正知道确切的原因。这些都属于推测。哭泣存在文化差异吗？例如，您是否研究过不同的民族？是的，2008 年进行了一项关于哭泣的大型全球调查。在不同的文化之间确实存在一些细微的差异，但总体而言，实际上也存在非常惊人的相似之处。
Are there other factors involved in men crying less than women, such as biological or physiological reasons? Yeah, there are likely some biological reasons. We haven't studied those yet to know exactly what they are, but we know that there's a number of biological differences between men and women. There are probably some socio-cultural factors as well. I think things are kind of improving in present times, but I think that, men have often been, like, socialized to not cry as crying as being seen as something weak or
男性比女性哭得少，是否还涉及其他因素，例如生物学或生理学原因？是的，很可能存在一些生物学原因。我们还没有研究过这些，不知道它们究竟是什么，但我们知道男性和女性之间存在许多生物学差异。可能也存在一些社会文化因素。我认为在当今时代情况有所改善，但我认为男性通常被社会化为不哭，因为哭泣被视为软弱或
vulnerable, and men have been more discouraged to cry compared to women, although I think there's some improvement in that area. Why do we cry tears of joy, and are they different somehow from the other types of tears that we might shed? Yeah, that's a good question. So tears of joy tend to be a bit less common than tears toward more distressing or negative stimuli. So most of the research has been focused on crying in response to distressing stimuli.
脆弱的表现，与女性相比，男性更不被鼓励哭泣，尽管我认为在这一领域有所改善。我们为什么会流下喜悦的泪水，它们与我们可能流下的其他类型的泪水有什么不同吗？嗯，这是一个好问题。所以，喜悦的泪水往往比针对更痛苦或负面刺激的泪水要少见一些。因此，大多数研究都集中在对痛苦刺激的哭泣反应上。
lie. For example, I don't know of any laboratory studies that have been able to induce positive tears. It's much more difficult to induce that. It's usually something really personally relevant, like someone gets married or has a baby or wins Olympic competition. Or some people might also respond to a beautiful artwork or a beautiful sunset. Some people are more sensitive to that type of positive response than others. But we don't really know anything about whether or not the biological mechanisms differ. What we do know is a common factor is that the emotion is intense and they have, you know, experience of physiological arousal in that moment where they're positive or negative is associated with crying, but it has to be a highly intense emotion. You talked a moment ago
例如，我不知道有什么实验室研究能够诱发积极的泪水。诱发这种泪水要困难得多。它通常是与个人高度相关的事情，比如某人结婚、生子或赢得奥运比赛。或者有些人也可能对美丽的艺术品或美丽的日落做出反应。有些人比其他人对这种积极反应更敏感。但我们对于生物机制是否不同一无所知。我们所知道的一个共同因素是情绪非常强烈，并且他们在那个时刻有生理唤醒的体验，无论是积极还是消极都与哭泣有关，但它必须是一种高度强烈的情绪。你刚才谈到了
about crying in the lab. How do you get people to cry in the lab and are there ethical considerations around doing that? Yeah, yeah. So my graduate school mentor, John Rottenberg, did some of that work. And, you know, I've worked on other studies where we elicited various emotions in the lab. And this is typically done with emotional films. So we used, one of the clips that was used was the champ. It's kind of an older film now. So I don't know if people are familiar with it, but it's the scene where the little boy is crying over the man who has died. And it's a pretty intense scene.
在实验室里哭泣。你是如何让人们在实验室里哭泣的？这样做有什么伦理方面的考虑吗？是的，是的。我的研究生导师约翰·罗滕伯格做过一些这样的工作。而且，我参与过其他研究，我们在实验室里诱发了各种情绪。这通常是通过情感电影来完成的。所以我们使用过，其中一个使用的片段是《舐犊情深》（The Champ）。这现在算是一部老电影了。所以我不知道人们是否熟悉它，但那是小男孩为死去的男人哭泣的场景。这是一个相当强烈的场景。
And I think in response to seeing the little boy cry and being in significant distress, it does often induce tears in people. But the problem with this is these are movies. Most people, when they're crying in daily life or not, some people might be watching sad movies, but most people are crying a more personally relevant situation. So it's really hard to replicate these in the lab. It's not really feasible. And like you mentioned, ethics, they'd also be kind of unethical to replicate some of these specific types of scenarios in the lab. But currently in some of my current work, we've been looking at using ambulatory methods in daily life.
我认为在看到小男孩哭泣并处于极度痛苦中时，这确实经常诱发人们的泪水。但问题在于这些是电影。大多数人在日常生活中哭泣时并不是这样，有些人可能会看悲伤的电影，但大多数人是在更具个人相关性的情况下哭泣。所以很难在实验室中复制这些场景。这并不真正可行。而且就像你提到的伦理问题，在实验室中复制这些特定类型的场景也可能是不道德的。但目前在我的一些工作中，我们一直在研究在日常生活中使用移动监测方法。
So using surveys on smartphones in combination with ambulatory physiosensors, so like passive sensing where people wear a device that can monitor cardiac activity, for example. And so we're currently trying to get more information about things that happen in the real world that I think will be particularly elucidating here. So if I were going to volunteer to be in one of your experiments, right, I have to sign a form that says, I agree to be made miserable in your laboratory. so I will weep. Yeah, so we haven't been doing the laboratory studies more recently because I think really
即在智能手机上使用调查问卷，结合移动生理传感器，比如被动传感，人们佩戴一个可以监测心脏活动的设备。所以我们目前正在尝试获取更多关于现实世界中发生的事情的信息，我认为这在这里会特别有启发性。所以如果我要自愿参加你们的实验，对吧，我必须签署一份表格，上面写着：我同意在你们的实验室里变得痛苦，这样我就会流泪。是的，所以我们最近没有做实验室研究，因为我认为真正
where we can move forward more is doing it in daily life. But yes, you have to have people consent and say they are going to be watching emotional stimuli and that they could be experiencing strong emotional responses. You definitely would have to tell people that as well. Which might also influence their responses. It's also artificial in that, you know, the experimenters are watching you. You're probably being videotaped. It's really awkward.
我们可以向前推进的是在日常生活中进行研究。但是是的，你必须让人们知情同意，并说明他们将观看情感刺激，并且他们可能会经历强烈的情绪反应。你绝对必须告诉人们这一点。这可能也会影响他们的反应。而且这在某种程度上是人为的，因为实验者在观察你。你可能正在被录像。这真的很尴尬。
and uncomfortable, and almost everyone reports feeling worse after crying in the lab. But in daily life, people more often report feeling better. So it's just not a good representation, I think, of what people are experiencing in real life. So that's common then, like having a good cry really does make you feel better? Yeah, it varies quite a bit, but there's definitely a good portion of people that report feeling better. It seems to depend on the social context. And the rates at which people report whether it's better or not vary based on how we ask. So if we just ask the general measure, do people think they feel better after crying, the majority report feeling better. But if we ask them about a very specific episode, then it goes down a bit. And then if we ask them like in the
而且不舒服，几乎每个人都报告说在实验室哭泣后感觉更糟。但在日常生活中，人们更多地报告感觉更好。所以我认为这并不能很好地代表人们在现实生活中所经历的事情。那么，痛快地哭一场真的能让你感觉好些，这很常见吗？是的，情况差异很大，但确实有很大一部分人报告感觉更好。这似乎取决于社会环境。人们报告感觉是否更好的比例取决于我们如何提问。如果我们只是问一个一般性的衡量标准，即人们是否认为哭泣后感觉更好，大多数人报告感觉更好。但如果我们问他们关于某个非常具体的事件，那么比例就会下降一点。然后如果我们问他们，比如在
moment, like right after they cried, then it goes down a bit more. So it seems to really, there might be some like bias and perception about crying when people are just thinking about it overall. Maybe certain ones stand out to them more than others. Maybe the crying takes longer for it to become beneficial, so maybe it doesn't happen right away. But it does seem that there's definitely a subset of situations in which people feel better after crying, and the social piece seems to be particularly important. So if people cry in a supportive social environment, they're much more likely to feel better after crying. So it might be that it's really the social piece that's making them feel better, not necessarily the crying itself, but there's also examples. A lot of people
那一刻，就在他们哭完之后，那么比例就会下降得更多。所以这似乎确实存在，当人们总体思考哭泣时，可能存在某种感知偏差。也许某些哭泣事件比其他事件更突出。也许哭泣需要更长时间才能产生益处，所以可能不会立即发生。但确实似乎有一部分情况人们在哭泣后感觉更好，而社会因素似乎特别重要。所以如果人们在支持性的社会环境中哭泣，他们哭泣后感觉更好的可能性要大得多。所以可能真正让他们感觉更好的是社会因素，而不一定是哭泣本身，但也有例子。很多人
cry alone, for example, and many people who cry alone also report feeling better. And one theoretical viewpoint is that the crying forces you to think about whatever's bothering you. So if you're crying, you can't really think about anything else. It kind of forces you to deal with it. Maybe you've been avoiding it and not thinking about it. But when you're crying about it, you have to think about it. So it might force you to reach a new kind of cognitive understanding of whatever it is that was bothering you. What areas of the brain are involved in crying? Is there some central location and are the tears that you, tears of distress, are they controlled in the same part of the brain as the tears of joy? Yeah, I wish we had that research. There's remarkably
例如独自哭泣，许多独自哭泣的人也报告感觉更好。一种理论观点是，哭泣迫使你去思考困扰你的事情。所以如果你在哭，你就不能真正去想别的事情。它在某种程度上迫使你去处理它。也许你一直在回避它，没有去想它。但当你为它哭泣时，你必须去想它。所以它可能会迫使你对困扰你的事情达成一种新的认知理解。大脑的哪些区域参与了哭泣？是否有某个中心位置？痛苦的泪水和喜悦的泪水是由大脑的同一部分控制的吗？是的，我希望我们有那样的研究。令人惊讶的是
been no neuroimaging studies of crying, emotional crying in humans. And so we don't know, but what I would suspect is given the strong ties to emotion, likely the other parts of the brain involved in emotion would be active. But similar to effective neuroscience research in general, we can't really separate positive and negative emotions very well in the brain. So it would likely involve some common regions like the amygdala, for example, that are involved in both positive and negative emotions, as well as parts of the central autonomic network that are involved in emotion expression and other like physiological processes underlying emotion. There are some specific reward regions of the brain, like the striatum that might be specific
目前还没有关于人类情绪性哭泣的神经影像学研究。所以我们不知道，但我怀疑，鉴于与情绪的紧密联系，大脑中参与情绪的其他部分可能会活跃。但与一般的情感神经科学研究类似，我们无法很好地在大脑中区分积极和消极情绪。所以它可能涉及一些共同区域，例如杏仁核，它参与积极和消极情绪，以及中央自主神经网络中参与情绪表达和情绪背后其他生理过程的部分。大脑中存在一些特定的奖励区域，例如纹状体，可能特定于
to positive things, but we don't really, we haven't studied this in the context. of crying. There has been some comparative biology research with animals making alarm cries, and it does seem like that there may be some emotional areas of the brain involved in that, like the amygdala as well as parts of the brain like the midbrain. But that's just a guess based on animal studies of distressed vocalizations. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill for-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499.
积极的事物，但我们并不真正了解，我们还没有在哭泣的背景下研究过这一点。有一些关于动物发出警报叫声的比较生物学研究，看起来大脑中确实可能涉及一些情绪区域，比如杏仁核以及中脑等大脑部分。但这只是基于动物痛苦叫声研究的猜测。您的夏天从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Nextgrill 四炉头燃气烧烤架开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅招待客人，仅需 499 美元。
This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price-in-valid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost.
这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，排除条款适用。详情请访问 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？足够了。足够去迷失自我了。
Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay.
或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得您预期的住宿体验。当您想要节省开支，而不是意外时。住哪里很重要。
Hilton, for the stay. Speaking of vocalizations, why do we humans sometimes vocalize when we cry and other times not? Yeah, the vocalizations are associated with more intense crying. I think usually when people are crying, they might want not everyone to hear about it, so they would probably usually avoid vocalizing if they're in a public situation. But maybe if they're at home, they might be more comfortable vocalizing,
希尔顿，为您提供理想住宿。说到发声，为什么我们人类有时哭泣时会发出声音，而有时不会？是的，发声与更强烈的哭泣有关。我认为通常当人们哭泣时，他们可能不想让每个人都听到，所以如果他们在公共场合，他们可能会避免发声。但如果他们在家里，他们可能会更自在地发声，
or if the crying is just so intense that they can't control the vocalization, it does seem to be associated with the intensity of the crime. And you mentioned studying other animals to understand this. emotion, but other animals don't cry, correct? I mean, there is some people think that they do and you can go on TikTok and see videos and, oh, that's that dog is crying, but dogs don't really shed tears. I mean, does any other animal cry, even primates? Right. Yeah, it's a good question. Now, I haven't worked directly with animals in my own research, but it has thought that crying in humans evolved initially from distress calls and other animals, but that it seemed to further develop in
或者如果哭泣太强烈以至于他们无法控制发声，这似乎确实与哭泣的强度有关。你提到了研究其他动物来理解这种情绪，但其他动物不会哭，对吧？我的意思是，有些人认为它们会，你可以在 TikTok 上看到视频，哦，那只狗在哭，但狗并不会真正流泪。我的意思是，有其他动物会哭吗，甚至是灵长类动物？对。是的，这是一个好问题。现在，我自己的研究中没有直接与动物合作，但人们认为人类的哭泣最初是从其他动物的痛苦呼叫进化而来的，但它似乎在
humans to have additional functions beyond the initial function was just so that the infant could get caregiving from its parent or to warn other other peers in your group of potential danger. So those were the initial biological functions. But humans, as we became more complex and have more complex social groups, crying seem to develop more other social types of functions as well because we do continue to cry in adulthood where there's other animals are more likely to show these cries in infancy. see. But based on the evidence we have, there doesn't seem to be evidence, any strong evidence that animals have emotional crying. There have been like some isolated case studies where people
人类中进一步发展，具有了超出最初功能的额外功能，最初的功能只是为了让婴儿从父母那里获得照顾，或者警告群体中的其他同伴潜在的危险。所以这些是最初的生物学功能。但是人类，随着我们变得更复杂并拥有更复杂的社会群体，哭泣似乎也发展出了更多其他社会类型的功能，因为我们确实在成年期继续哭泣，而其他动物更有可能在婴儿期表现出这些哭泣。明白。但根据我们现有的证据，似乎没有证据，没有任何强有力的证据表明动物有情绪性哭泣。曾经有一些孤立的案例研究，人们
have made these claims, but the only more systematic study that's been conducted of zookeepers to ask them about crime, their animals did not reveal any significant evidence of emotional crying in animals. So where we do see that animals might produce some tears, it's probably a more form their eyes irritated and more form of reflexive tear or maybe if they're doing a lot of motor movements, maybe it's squeezing out more liquid from the eyes because of a physical response and not from an emotional response. Is there anything contagious about crying? I mean, if you're in a place where, you know, you're at a funeral and somebody starts crying and pretty soon, you know, the whole room is crying. Is there that kind of psychological contagion to crying? Yeah. Well, I think
声称过这一点，但唯一对动物园管理员进行的更系统的研究，询问他们关于动物哭泣的情况，并没有揭示任何动物情绪性哭泣的显著证据。所以我们确实看到动物可能会产生一些眼泪，这可能更多是由于它们的眼睛受到刺激，更多是一种反射性泪水，或者如果它们进行了大量的运动，也许是因为身体反应而从眼睛中挤出了更多的液体，而不是出于情绪反应。哭泣有传染性吗？我的意思是，如果你在一个地方，比如你在葬礼上，有人开始哭泣，很快，你知道，整个房间都在哭泣。哭泣有那种心理传染性吗？是的。嗯，我认为
there's a couple pieces to it. One is if other people are crying, you might from more crying, but also one of the main triggers for crying is empathy. So when you're saying other people cry, like in that video clip I mentioned earlier, there's the child's crying there, you're going to be more likely to experience. It's going to help elicit that empathetic response. If someone's crying, you really can see how distressed they are. It's really visible. And so that might be more likely to elicit that crying in you as well. You know, people often feel quite self-conscious about crying. I mean, it doesn't, it's not something that's necessarily valued in social situations.
这有几个方面。一个是如果其他人正在哭泣，你可能会因为更多的哭泣而受到影响，但哭泣的主要触发因素之一是同理心。所以当你看到其他人哭泣时，就像我之前提到的那个视频片段，那里有孩子的哭泣，你更有可能经历这种情绪。这将有助于诱发那种同理心反应。如果有人在哭，你真的能看到他们有多痛苦。这是非常明显的。所以这可能也更有可能在你身上诱发哭泣。你知道，人们经常对哭泣感到非常难为情。我的意思是，这在社会场合中并不一定是被重视的。
Are people seen as weaker or less competent when they're crying? Yeah, that can occur. So I think that's why people tend to prefer to cry or find it more helpful to cry when they're among individuals who provide more comforting reactions. So I think there are certain situations like if you're at the workplace where it's not considered great to cry in most situations in a work environment. There might be some exceptions to that. But most individuals will report having at least
人们在哭泣时会被视为更软弱或能力更差吗？是的，这种情况可能会发生。所以我认为这就是为什么人们倾向于更喜欢在那些提供更多安慰反应的人群中哭泣，或者觉得在那种情况下哭泣更有帮助。所以我认为确实存在某些情况，比如如果你在工作场所，在大多数工作环境的情况下，哭泣被认为是不太好的。这可能有一些例外。但大多数人会报告至少有
Some people may be a partner or a best friend, like someone or a therapist, like someone that they feel safe crying in. And so usually there's quite a bit of variability. But some people might feel more comfortable than others. Some people might have been like criticized as a child for crying, especially boys. Or people who have undergone trauma, emotional abuse may be less comfortable crying because it shows a vulnerability to do that in front of others. I mentioned in the introduction that you've done some research into crying in therapy.
有些人可能是伴侣或最好的朋友，比如某人或治疗师，比如他们觉得可以安全地在他们面前哭泣的人。所以通常会有相当多的变异。但有些人可能比其他人更自在。有些人可能在童年时期因哭泣而受到批评，尤其是男孩。或者经历过创伤、情感虐待的人可能不太自在哭泣，因为在他人面前这样做会表现出脆弱。我在介绍中提到你做过一些关于治疗中哭泣的研究。
what have you looked at and what have you found? Yeah, so I haven't done that work directly, but I did a review paper on it of the studies that have been done. And the studies that have been done have all been relatively sort of small-scale studies based on self-reports. So the knowledge we have is limited. But I'm also a clinical psychologist and do therapy myself and have experienced, you know, like patients crying in therapy.
你研究了什么，发现了什么？是的，我没有直接做那项工作，但我对已经完成的研究做了一篇综述论文。而且已经完成的研究都是基于自我报告的相对小规模的研究。所以我们拥有的知识是有限的。但我也是一名临床心理学家，自己也做治疗，并且经历过，你知道，比如患者在治疗中哭泣。
But I do think that crying is a really important part of the therapeutic process. It's often a place where patients feel most comfortable crying. in expressing their emotions. And being able to process your emotions in a safe environment is really important in therapy for a variety of mental health disorders, particularly for those who have experienced trauma, I think. And so I think by being able to cry in therapy and process those emotions in a helpful manner, that that is particularly important.
但我确实认为哭泣是治疗过程中非常重要的一部分。这通常是患者觉得最自在哭泣的地方。在表达他们的情绪时。并且能够在安全的环境中处理你的情绪，我认为对于各种心理健康障碍的治疗非常重要，特别是对于那些经历过创伤的人。所以我认为通过能够在治疗中哭泣并以有益的方式处理这些情绪，这一点特别重要。
But in some of the research, we found that also not only do the patients often cry, but therapists sometimes cry as well. And that that can often be experienced positively by both therapists and patient as part of like that building that rapport and that connection, you know, if done in an appropriate way where you're not taking the attention, you know, away from the patient. But there's some differences in people have different modalities that they practice and some therapists might be more comfortable crying than others depending on, you know, the approach that they're taking.
但在一些研究中，我们发现不仅患者经常哭泣，治疗师有时也会哭泣。而且这通常会被治疗师和患者积极地体验为建立融洽关系和联系的一部分，你知道，如果以适当的方式进行，你没有把注意力从患者身上转移走。但人们在实践中有不同的模式，一些治疗师可能比其他人更自在地哭泣，这取决于他们所采取的方法。
What got you interested in studying crying? Yes, when I was in grad school, my graduate mentor, John Rottenberg, collaborated. with Advingerharts in the Netherlands. And he had just collected that big days that I mentioned earlier, and they were looking for students to help look at the data and write papers from it. And so that's where it all started. And it's always fascinating me how a few people in the world study crying, it's gotten better.
是什么让你对研究哭泣感兴趣？是的，当我在读研究生时，我的研究生导师约翰·罗滕伯格与荷兰的阿德·温格哈茨（Ad Vingerhoets）进行了合作。他刚刚收集了我之前提到的那些大数据，他们正在寻找学生来帮助查看数据并撰写论文。所以这就是一切开始的地方。而且世界上研究哭泣的人很少，这总是让我着迷，情况有所好转。
But it's still, given like, the ubiquity importance of human crying, it's still very surprising to me how little research is actually done and, like, how we have no neuroimaging studies, a human crying. And it certainly has its challenges, but I, you know, I'm surprised that there's like such a small number of people in the world studying it. So that's just kept me, you know, intrigued. It can be harder to get funding for studies of normal human behavior. Like most of my work is in mental health than from the NIH.
但鉴于人类哭泣的普遍性和重要性，研究工作之少仍然让我感到非常惊讶，而且我们没有任何关于人类哭泣的神经影像学研究。这当然有其挑战，但我，你知道，我很惊讶世界上研究它的人数如此之少。所以这让我一直保持着好奇心。获得正常人类行为研究的资助可能更难。比如我的大部分工作是在心理健康领域，而不是来自 NIH。
So it's much easier to get funding for things that are of public health significance, like mental health disorders. Whereas while crying might be associated mental health disorders, everyone cries. It's not a pathological thing. So I think part of it is it's harder to get like big grants to really study it too. are you yourself much of a cryer? Yeah, I would say I'm probably pretty average, yeah, in terms of that. But, yeah, I've noticed it varies over my life, too. Like sometimes in my life, maybe I would cry more easily than others.
所以为具有公共卫生意义的事情（如心理健康障碍）获得资助要容易得多。然而，虽然哭泣可能与心理健康障碍有关，但每个人都会哭。这不是一种病理现象。所以我认为部分原因是很难获得大额拨款来真正研究它。你自己是一个爱哭的人吗？是的，我想我可能相当普通，是的，就这一点而言。但是，是的，我也注意到它在我的一生中也在变化。比如有时在我的生活中，也许我比其他时候更容易哭。
I think for me as well as a lot of people, like if you're having more stress or not sleeping as well or just, you know, have too much going on that you might be more likely to cry than other times where, you know, things are going more smoothly. So that's another factor that might predict, you know, whether or not someone cries easily, too. Is there some kind of a metric people can use to know that their crying has moved into the danger zone if you cried too much? I mean, what's sort of an average? How often do people cry? Yeah.
我认为对我以及很多人来说，如果你有更多的压力，或者睡眠不好，或者只是，你知道，手头的事情太多，你可能比其他事情进展顺利的时候更容易哭。所以这是另一个可能预测某人是否容易哭泣的因素。人们是否可以使用某种指标来知道他们的哭泣已经进入了危险区，如果你哭得太多了？我的意思是，平均水平是多少？人们多久哭一次？是的。
If I remember correctly, I think women report cry maybe two to three times a month on average and men, it could be like zero to one. But the really important thing I want to impress is that there's no like a pathological. number, like if you cry this much, it's bad, or if you don't cry at all, it's bad. That's really important to keep in mind because sometimes people will email me and they'll be concerned. Like, I'm crying too much. What can I do? I'm not crying enough.
如果我没记错的话，我想女性平均每月报告哭泣两到三次，而男性可能是零到一次。但我真正想强调的重要一点是，没有所谓的病理数字，比如如果你哭这么多，那就不好，或者如果你根本不哭，那也不好。这一点非常重要，因为有时人们会给我发电子邮件，他们会感到担心。比如，我哭得太多了。我该怎么办？我哭得不够多。
What's wrong with me? There's quite a bit of normal variation in human crying. And it's not anything to be concerned about unless it starts, if you feel like it's impacting your functioning, your ability to connect socially with others, if it's having a negative impact on your relationships, or if you feel like you're not able to healthily, express your emotions and deal with them in a helpful way, that's when it might be a concern. And maybe seeking something like psychotherapy can be helpful. But there's no magic number. Some people are perfectly comfortable not crying very much, whereas other people like to have
我怎么了？人类哭泣存在相当多的正常变异。除非它开始，如果你觉得它正在影响你的功能，你与他人进行社交联系的能力，如果它对你的人际关系产生了负面影响，或者如果你觉得你无法健康地表达你的情绪并以有益的方式处理它们，那才可能是个问题。也许寻求心理治疗之类的东西会有所帮助。但没有神奇的数字。有些人完全可以接受不怎么哭，而另一些人则喜欢有
that experience of crying. So there's a lot of normal variation. What about suppressing crying? Can that be harmful to people? Yeah, there is some self-report evidence that suppressing tears can be harmful as well as chronically suppressing other emotions in general. Certainly there's some situations we have to do that to function in society. But overall, if you're chronically suppressing tears and your other emotions and you're not, you don't have any safe place to experience those emotions in a healthy manner, that that over time can be unhelpful. And so I would encourage people who are experiencing that to find more healthy outlets to be able to experience their emotion. Are there neurological or psychological disorders that make people cry more or make them
那种哭泣的体验。所以有很多正常的变异。压抑哭泣呢？这对人们有害吗？是的，有一些自我报告证据表明，压抑眼泪以及长期压抑其他情绪通常可能是有害的。当然，在某些情况下，我们必须这样做才能在社会中发挥作用。但总的来说，如果你长期压抑眼泪和其他情绪，并且你没有任何安全的地方以健康的方式体验这些情绪，那么随着时间的推移，这可能是不健康的。所以我鼓励那些经历这种情况的人找到更健康的出口，以便能够体验他们的情绪。有没有神经或心理障碍会导致人们哭得更多或
cry inappropriately? Yeah, so there is some evidence that people who have depression and anxiety might cry a bit more, but it's not a linear relationship. So because on the most severe end, people have more severe depression or really severe trauma might not cry at all because they experience more emotional numbing. And also some medications like SSRIs can increase the threshold decried. So if people aren't necessarily, they might not cry as much as they used to. There is a neurological condition called pathological crying or pseudovolular affect. It involves pathological crying or it can involve laughter too. But what we know of that, it seems to have different mechanisms and that the person is often not really experiencing an intense emotion. It's more of a
不适当地哭泣？是的，有一些证据表明患有抑郁症和焦虑症的人可能会哭得更多，但这并不是一种线性关系。因为在最严重的一端，患有更严重抑郁症或遭受严重创伤的人可能根本不会哭，因为他们经历了更多的情绪麻木。而且一些药物（如 SSRI）也会提高哭泣的阈值。所以如果人们不一定，他们可能不会像以前那样哭泣。有一种神经系统疾病叫做病理性哭泣或假性延髓情绪。它涉及病理性哭泣，或者也可能涉及笑。但据我们所知，它似乎有不同的机制，而且患者通常并没有真正经历强烈的情绪。这更多是一种
basic neurological thing in that it's not emotionally driven. But, but, But it's fairly rare disorders, so we don't know a whole lot about it. So what are you working on now and what research questions do you want to answer? You mentioned that we don't have a lot of neuroimaging of people crying. Is that something that you're looking to do, or are you working in other areas? Yeah, so neuroimaging studies are pretty expensive to fund. So that hasn't been my focus right now. But what I'm currently doing is I have a number of studies going on of doing ambulatory
基本的神经学现象，因为它不是由情绪驱动的。但是，但是，但是这是相当罕见的疾病，所以我们对它了解不多。那么你现在在做什么，你想回答什么研究问题？你提到我们没有太多关于人们哭泣的神经影像学研究。这是你想要做的事情吗，还是你在其他领域工作？是的，神经影像学研究的资助非常昂贵。所以这不是我目前的重点。但我目前正在做的是，我正在进行一些研究，进行移动
physiology with daily self-reports of emotion. So I've added crying measures onto some of those ongoing studies so we can better understand the physiological correlates of crying in the real world and other factors too, like social factors or what types of things people are crying to. So I'm hoping this data will give us more information on how crying affects people in the real world. And one of my most recent studies is also in adults with autism where we're looking at emotional processes there where I've also added a crying measure too. Dr. Bosma, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been interesting to chat with you.
生理监测和每日情绪自我报告。所以我已经在其中一些正在进行的研究中添加了哭泣测量，这样我们就可以更好地了解现实世界中哭泣的生理相关性以及其他因素，比如社会因素或人们因什么而哭泣。所以我希望这些数据能让我们更多地了解哭泣在现实世界中如何影响人们。我最近的一项研究也是针对自闭症成年人的，我们正在研究那里的情绪过程，我也添加了一个哭泣测量。拜尔斯玛博士，我想感谢您今天加入我的节目。与您交谈很有趣。
Yeah, thank you. It's been great talking to you about this. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wierman. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills.
是的，谢谢。和你谈论这个真是太棒了。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢您所听到的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有意见或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·维尔曼制作。感谢您的收听。美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。
Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day. with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state.
在 Ralph's 享受更多省钱方式，比如每个过道的低价。当你下载 Ralph's 应用程序时，你可以每周通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。此外，你可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑节省高达 1 美元。在 Ralph's，你每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。所以每天省大钱总是很容易。伴随着储蓄和奖励。Ralph's SoCal 超过 150 年。储蓄可能因州而异。
Fuel restrictions apply. See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
燃油限制适用。详情请参阅网站。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。